all right guys bang-bang I'm super
excited by this conversation we're all
got a bunch of coffee ready to go Jeff's
here dude this could be fun go to it
yeah thanks for coming to do it let's
start off with your background pre
founders fund because uh I don't think
that you were on a path to become an
investor no I was I was definitely I
don't think I was really on any path it
was a a pathless existence prior to
probably actually starting my company
and so the back stories grew up in
Canada sort of a pretty unstable
childhood and so when I graduated from
from college I was really want to
optimize for stability so I joined a
large American multinational company
Procter and Gamble and quickly realized
that a stability wasn't for me I found
it extremely boring but I was I knew
that I wanted to do something more
entrepreneurial and so I stuck around
until I got my green card and then
shortly after I did I got out of there
and got to San Francisco and decided
that I wanted to actually optimize for
for hanging around smart people rather
than stability and I figured if I could
just meet a lot of really smart
interesting people I'd sort of figure
out what I wanted to wanted to do I'm
sort of serendipitously met a number of
the folks that were sort of in at the
time it was called the PayPal mafia just
through friends and friends of friends
ended up getting recruited to join Peter
Thiel's hedge fund which is called
clarium capital and so I joined that
hedge fund sort of a pretty undefined
role sort of a you know pretty unclear
role sort of unclear what I was going to
be doing but I knew I'd be working with
extremely smart people Peter at Peter
and others there my timing was
unfortunately really bad I joined I
joined clarium two weeks before Lehman
Brothers collapse so I could not have
picked a worse time for my furry into
that the world of Finance but the upshot
of that experience was I shared an
office with an absolutely brilliant
engineer this guy Trevor Austin and we
ended up becoming France and decided we
want to start a business together and
you know the advice I give entrepreneurs
now is you shouldn't start a business
for the sake of starting a business
you should have sort of a really clear
mission of what you want to do I
actually didn't follow that advice I
knew that I just want to do something
entrepreneurial so did Trevor
and so I ended up cycling through a few
concepts initially we landed on
something called eudorus which was
basically I would say actually an early
version of Pinterest meets Instagram
executed horribly so people who sort of
tag places brands etcetera and their
photos in 2009 the execution was
terrible we got no users of sort of a
laughingstock
you know we raised half a million
dollars from VCS including Founders Fund
in the business was was clearly gonna go
nowhere but uh but and Trevor to his to
his credit sort of realized that and
ended up joining Palantir so I was sort
of on my own there was a founder you
know we had a few hundred K left in the
bank and I was like I just can't fail
because for me failure wasn't an option
I mean it's like I had nowhere else yeah
I could have gone maybe going back to
Clara or something but I ended up sort
of pivoting the business putting
together a new team of co-founders ash
and oz and we ended up turning that
business and this thing called top guest
which I think the pit the pithy way to
describe it would be sort of Cambridge
analytic ofor hotels and airlines and so
we were we were pulling a lot of social
data with people's permission we got we
got the permission and giving them
loyalty points from programs like United
Mileage Plus Starwood Preferred Guest at
the time at cetera in exchange for
sharing their social data so sort of a
enabling SAS tool for these hotels and
airlines there's a circa 2010 realize
that business you know realise
relatively get it relatively good at
selling into customers we didn't have
great product market fete so we ended up
selling it it was a reasonably good you
know not huge but reasonably good
financial outcome for me went from you
know $40,000 in credit card debt to you
know having you know some money in my
bank account which was nice that was a
joke that's the first step to like
financial freedom right it's go from
negative to positive and then worry
about what the positive number is oh it
was RIT was really life-changing so sort
of like you know I'd lived my early
career had been very much in sort of
this matrix type environment so you know
you're at a place like Procter & Gamble
there's this existing structure it's
been around for hundreds of years you
know there was a lot less glare and it
felt a lot more generative you could you
could sort of do new things
a lot of openness to folks trying
different projects and then when we
actually laughed and we started the
business the startup you're just
completely out of the matrix and and so
sort of like you've somehow have to have
to just make it work and then you know
after I sold the company what I realized
was I wasn't very good at executing
these these technology business says but
I felt like the ideas were actually
quite goods the idea for you Doris I
thought was very good idea later
you know proven by folks like Instagram
and Pinterest you executed phenomenally
well you know the idea for top guests I
would argue you know what we're trying
to do is make travel more personal I'd
sort of argue that Airbnb sort of ended
up doing that in sort of a different way
and so figured that I should try and
optimize in a direction towards towards
figuring out what ideas are gonna work
in the future but not actually having to
build the things the things the things
myself which is what led me to Founders
Fund what what um one of things you said
that I've heard over and over again
about Peter's just entire world is you
came onto clarium with like an undefined
role and I think a lot of people
especially in start-up world like
they're trying to like textbook hey what
should I do okay we have a role let's go
find somebody and if you listen to you
know Peter Thiel Keith Raboy so a lot of
these folks don't look fine young people
who are kind of undervalued given what
their potential is and even if you don't
have a role like just get them in the
door and if they're good they'll figure
out how to create value right and it
sounds like that was something that you
kind of were the person being plugged in
without that defined role was that
something that you thought was a
positive or a negative at the time I
thought I thought it was hugely positive
and one of the things that does
engenders tremendous loyalty so if you
give a young person you know a chance
who really doesn't have a traditional
background I didn't go to Stanford nor
Ivy League school I was working in you
know CPG marketing and so and so when
someone gives you a chance and takes a
chance on you engenders a lot of loyalty
and and there is an ARB so you know
ideally you know whoever's and we try
and do this a bedrock my firm now we
like to hire you know young curious
folks who maybe aren't from the
traditional traditional backgrounds we
look for that with our entrepreneurs as
well
there's obviously an our bond the price
thing that you can get if you find these
people and your and you're right about
it and then over time the ARB closes but
but but over time you know you can sort
of build these are these powerful
positive some relationships with folks
that that was sort of underestimated by
the market for sure and so when you
started to optimize for the investing
side versus the execution side you went
straight to founders fund oh yes okay
and what was kind of the thought process
there you were just going to invest in
early-stage kind of full stack what was
kind of the idea well the thought
process the thought process on my end
was I really wanted to be an ambassador
into VC and and they were the VCS that I
knew that I was that I was friendly with
some of them and they were the ones that
gave me a job I don't think if I had I
don't think if I'd applied to benchmark
or Sequoia they would have they would
have reviewed my resume but the founders
fund took me you know somewhat seriously
and I went in there for some interviews
and really initially it was sort of I
thought I'd stick around for a year and
then start another business I mean my
whole ex-post analysis of sort of the
top guest eudorus experience was the
execution was terrible yet we still
managed to make money for ourselves and
for the ambassadors I thought if we
could actually start another business
where the execution was good that could
actually be very good so I was quite
anchored on going off and starting
another company but really what happened
was I just fell in love with with
venture capital investing and one of the
awesome things about founders from one
of the one of the particularly awesome
things is that you know I joined quite
junior I was the newest person on the
investment team but I was empowered to
make investments and really the only way
you can learn about investing is through
actually independently sort of sourcing
and making investments obviously you
debate things as a team and people weigh
in and really my second deal on the team
I'd been there for four months was left
I sort of saw it out of the corner of my
eye and led the first financing round
and in that company after they'd pivoted
from Zimride and joined the board and
then from there it sort of it sort of
kept going and just got more and more
into it and excited about excited about
sort of finding these find these these
interesting opportunities and working
with these great founders why did you
like lift what was the thought process
well let's see you know at the time
so rewind doctor 2012 uber was just a
black car business they were
experimenting with taxis they hadn't
done any of the uber acts tough so there
was no concept of peer-to-peer
ride-sharing there was no concept of
regular people driving other regular
people around there were two companies
in 2012 that started experimenting with
that it was lyft and sidecar were the
two and quite frankly you know one of
the things that a lot of the people at
the time were joking about was you had
these couple dozen lift cars in the city
they had these fuzzy pink mustaches on
them and those caught my eye so I
downloaded the app and tried it and
ended up meeting meeting with the
founders with my colleague Scott Nolan
and and just really falling for the
founders vision of what peer-to-peer
ride-sharing could unlock and they
really did pioneer that idea of regular
people driving other regular people
you know mount the sidecar people as
well they seemed a lot less good than
left and then they're sort of these you
know one of the things I like to sort of
keep in mind as an investor is
oftentimes the very small things the
things that people don't think much
about I can actually be very important
and so you take the name left it's sort
of a positive friendly name ubers sort
of this you know sort of snobby snobby
name so so there's a sense which I
thought was sort of a more friendly
brand and that translated from a
business standpoint into the founders
even very early on correctly focusing on
optimizing for supplies whenever you're
building a marketplace obviously you've
got to get supply gotta get demand they
correctly identified was we have to make
this an incredible experience for the
drivers the riders will come like there
is demand to get around cities cheaper
without having to drive and so they
really optimized to the extreme for
making it a great experience for the
drivers things like the fist-bump which
is one of the things they did early on
on you know encouraging conversation I
remember being on the board I I don't
really like talking very much in cars so
I kept trying to try to convince we can
you do a silent button please and Logan
the CEO kept saying no we're not doing
that it's not friendly we're friendly
and I was like come on I need a sila
button they turned out they were right
and so they did all these things early
on to optimize for supply and and
and yeah you know remember having the
conversation with with some of my
partners at Founders Fund and the
question at the time we invested at sort
of a sub 100 million dollar valuation
question was can this ten acts can we
see this being a billion dollar company
and sort of you know three of the
partners thought thought it could be and
one thought it couldn't be
and and luckily it's it's grown into a
much bigger company than that yeah the
personal side car is a blast from the
past in 2014 in San Francisco that's
actually the first ride-sharing company
that I downloaded was inside and then
they went out of business in like two
three years later and with lyft people
forget the pink mustaches and the fist
bump like it was kind of weird right but
it was if you were in the group right or
kind of in that Club it was almost like
a point of pride right versus the other
ones who just didn't have that type of
stuff and then you guys invested in a
number of different rounds right not
just that first time we did the first
one and we did we did some we did some
fall on investing you know the the
challenge with that company and and it's
you know now the company is I would
argue executing far better than uber and
and is a much a much more well-run
company it's easy to sort of gloss over
the hard times but the challenge with
that business was we're actually
competing against a ferociously
ferociously aggressive competitor Anubha
and so you know at the time 2012 2013
2014 2015
I mean that was a formidable company to
be competing against and they they very
quickly wised up to the fact that peer
to peer was actually going to be the
future of this market cloned left by
launching new barracks had more access
to capital or were able to raise a more
capital and we were in sort of a crazy
price war and war for market share and
war for raising capital because through
both very capital intensive businesses
to get to scale with um with uber and so
it was a really rocky road and those
founders John and Logan I think our
heroic heroic and like massively
underestimated
survive those early years quite frankly
was also my first board so sort of me
the founders we had one other one other
board member and emotionally it was a
pretty crazy roller coaster as a first
board seat as a you know 20-something VC
what talk to me about the
decision-making process inside a
founders fund right cuz you know most
venture capital funds have a pretty
standardized and strict hey we're gonna
meet every Monday we're gonna have the
founders come in and pitch and like you
know we'd have to get the consensus or
some majority and like it operates like
a VC fund everything I've heard is
founders funds very very different and
it'll lead to this idea that I have of
like founders fund is one of the only
firms that has original thought left but
kind of how does how did decisions get
made internally that's different than
some of these other firms sure so you
know I can't speak for how it works
today haven't been there for a few years
and since we started bedrock but uh but
back then yeah it was a you know and
anyone was empowered to source
investments if you're on the investment
team you can source investments and then
you've you've got to build a really
strong case and there's a lot of
spirited and intense debate and a
willingness to really hear out different
perspectives and and and try and get to
the truth about a company and so I
remember you know before I'd even joined
the team I was I was invited on an
off-site that that they were organizing
and I remember that I would sort of
pulled into this late night debate about
a prospective investment even though I
had sort of very limited context and you
know my opinion was sort of heard out
and valued and taken into account and
that is kind of the firm it is there's a
it's a it's a lot less you know top-down
hierarchical than I think I think many
of the other firms are and we've we've
really tried to take a page from that
playbook and how we build bedrock for
sure and Lessing on founders fund just
take aways from working with Peter and
and I think he's become over time like
this mythical figure hub but we talked
to people who are spending a lot of time
with him he is actually very rational
he's very kind of pragmatic except like
we're just do you take away from working
with someone like that
well lots to start we don't have that
much time
I mean the reality I've learned more
from learn more from working with them
than I've learned from from any other
any other sort of person that I've
worked with in my life or any other
experience or just you know tremendous
tremendous amount of learning from him
you know I'd say I was very lucky to
have have started working for him before
he was fully valued by the markets I
think he was he was seen as very
talented very successful but he's
obviously become much more successful
sense um you know I'd say that the
number one learning that I took away
would be you have to analyze businesses
things things things happen in life the
world on all of these different layers
and actually the most interesting and
important insights are these unused
subtextual layers and so that leads one
to actually you need be quite
interdisciplinary so you need to think
about the psychology around a business
you need to think about psychology of
the founders psychosocial ey other
investors might might miss an
opportunity um sort of wha-what-what
sort of why the company why the business
model would resonate and sort of a
really long time horizon and so it's
sort of these these multiple layers and
and quite frankly drilling down on
seemingly small decisions that
entrepreneurs have maids like well why
did you why did you launch this at this
period of time or what why is this the
name of the company or why did you hire
this specific person if you actually
drill down deep enough these can yield
these types of questions can yield very
important insights and then obviously
the sort of ethos of questioning
questioning things that that most folks
would just would just assume are true
questioning you know conventional wisdom
and always trying to get to your own
your own perspective and and that the
only way you can learn that is is really
through in osmosis of working with
someone for a really long period of time
and so you can't can't teach in a class
you sort of have to have to observe it
firsthand over many years I was I was
lucky to have had that experience and
then you guys leave in start bedrock
what was the idea for behind doing that
well the idea was really I'd had a
amazing run at Founders Fund and it sort
of been an amazing experience got to
invest in his phenomenal economy
work with great entrepreneurs across
multiple different sectors you know new
bank in Brazil fen tack rigged up which
were now large investors in a bedrock
and I'd also along the way built just a
great business relationship and
friendship with my now partner at
bedrock Eric Stromberg he was actually
the first entrepreneur I invested in a
founders fund right after I joined he
was building a Netflix for e-books
called oyster we'd been friends before
that I then worked with him as a board
member and he was the CEO and we had
sort of a very unique very unique yin
and yang in terms of a business
partnership and I'd never lost my desire
to build to build something of my own
and so sort of this question of is there
is there a way to do what what we love
doing which is venture investing but
also a sort of get get back out of the
matrix a little bit and try and create
our own universe and so that was kind of
the thought process and and and the
strategy is really is really to not make
very many investments we don't think
there are very many good companies and
so it's sort of we go go quite slow
we've only make a few investments every
you know every quarter and then we
really concentrate Capital triple triple
quadruple down into into into the things
that work so so so far so good
yeah and what does that look like when
you say kind of build these concentrated
bets because I think there that was a
very popular strategy in kind of early
days of venture capital right you know
sequoias first one I think had like nine
investments in it right and then we went
through a phase of like we'll call it
spray-and-pray right where it was let's
put 30 40 50 companies in a fund and now
you know there's you guys I think even
like the cha moth and kind of social
capital world that there's a couple
people were saying hey wait a minute
this concentrated bed idea is actually
better if you're right on the on the bet
what does that look like in terms of
when do you first start to invest and
then do you invest in every round from
there kind of what's the strategy in
terms of building that concentrated you
know kind of allocation sure so the
strategy is that the companies that are
really working we never want them to
actually go to market and do a financing
process and so that's sort of the basic
the basic ethos is in theory if you're
an entrepreneur and you have a business
that's really were
and you like your existing investors
they don't mess with you they give you
advice they're sounding boards they
don't try and run the business for you
which is something that we're very you
know religious but we don't we don't
want to run the business through the
founders you shouldn't actually have to
waste time going up and down Sand Hill
Road pitching a lot of firms the
Capitals just be very easy to get as you
hit milestones as you grow so in
practice we've done that with with rig
up which is a marketplace for
blue-collar labor um and you know we
invested initially in the series B right
after we started the firm we've invested
I think six subsequent times since then
such that we've scaled up what was
initially a 1 million dollar position a
little over 1 million - north of this
point 85 million dollars into that into
that single company and and and in order
to execute this strategy you actually
have to the founders have to actually
like you and so we we actually try and
we try we try and find you know that's
sort of a underrated underrated
attribute of being a good VC is you you
help sort of have to have the right
chemistry with the founders I mean not
not every VC is for every founder I'm
not for everyone you know not every
founders for me Eric's same thing
they're sort of you know you sort of
have to have that chemistry and if you
have that you can really concentrate
capital the ones that are working so
strategy is basically if they're good we
don't ever want anyone else to see them
and part of this strategy is you'll
invest seed series a do you want to come
in in the kind of a or the be like like
where do you start that relationship and
then from there you guys are kind of the
the sugar daddy if you will and if
everything goes well so there's sort of
one we're trying to optimize the game
sort of a one vector the vector is
basically the current fund we're
investing out of manages 350 million
dollars and that we want to at least 6x
the fond and so we have to find at least
six companies over the course of a few
years each of which will return 350
million dollars and so if you have that
as sort of your your vector that you're
trying to optimize for you actually
can't really have any other rules
because doing that in and of itself is
just is just so hard and so it's this
it's this sort of crazy search problem
you've got to find these companies
somehow and you have to
can get get to a narrative that you
actually believe that's true as an
investment team on why over many years
we can scale up a position such that can
return the entire fund and so that leads
us to being pretty agnostic in terms of
when we first get involved I'd say that
you know seed series a mostly series
sort of Series A Series B tends to be
for us the right place because it's
moment in time where there's there's
something that you can sort of tell is
working but not everyone can tell it's
working so you can sort of get involved
at a moment in time before sort of
everyone realizes it's work and you know
we sort of did that with with a company
called clear bet we did it with with um
with the athletic and others but uh no
rules beyond beyond we're trying to
trying to find a number of companies
that will return three hundred fifty
million dollars a piece I love it
one of the things that you uh you were
very loud about early on that I think
people kind of were like what the hell
is he talking about and now has become a
popular term is a narrative violation
and when I first saw you say on Twitter
I literally remember saying to myself
like I don't know if he's right or not
but that is going to [ __ ] fly if it
catches on because it's just such a
clear articulation of an idea where did
that come from and kind of like why is
that the thing that you guys really kind
of latched on to sure so you know I will
I will give the disclaimer that I do
worry that it's B it's become somewhat
somewhat is really caught on very
powerfully and whenever everyone starts
using a term others always a risk that
it's that's being way overused right now
so I do want to I do want to note that I
that I that I've definitely I'm
definitely using it less these days it
is still ours yeah nearer narrative
violating his own term I might be
narrative violate you know I think
there's these orthogonal terms that we
like so there's this one that actually
someone who I met over Twitter came up
with which I've sort of I'm gonna shame
lessly ape which is narrative narrative
void and so we like to find these
companies where there is there's just no
narrative around them there's sort of
these weird idiosyncratic businesses um
you know I think one could argue that
something like something like a a lambda
school was that when we invested
certainly
narrative violation would be would be
rigged up where you sort of have all
this energy around around climate clean
energy and and and and sort of there was
early on the business initially started
off in the oil and gas industry as a
marketplace for labor there that was a
very unpopular sector sort of ignored in
terms of the popular narrative and then
so so that would be a narrative
violation you know something like
laminate was a narrative void that was
sort of no one's really categorized what
it was and and then there's this whole
idea of narrative mirages which is these
ceases everyone knows tend to be
incredibly heard like and these popular
narratives can really lead to very
frenzied behavior and and we want to
always always avoid those and so I think
where we initially I think I initially
heard the term on it maybe as a Jordan
Peterson podcast I think he he may have
used it he's in a very different context
we use it in an investing context we're
talking about markets companies I think
he used it in sort of a different
context and it it sort of stuck with us
and we wanted to see could we build out
a build out sort of thought piece around
this we wrote our letter which we
published our website in 2018 and really
didn't do much to get it out there and
over the last few years it sort of has
has really just taken off and sort of
really been been read by but by lots of
folks and people people reach out all
the time so it's this idea of you know
most popular narratives you know are
sort of they're often true but people
often believe they're more true than
they are or something like that it's you
know question it yeah and and part of
this is like in investing the best
investments to make are the
non-consensus investment and you got to
be right rest if you do something
different than everyone else and you're
right there's a lot of money to be made
if you do something that's different
than everyone else and you're wrong then
like you're just the idiot right it's
kind of way I think about it and so the
narrative violation it's not just about
hey everyone thinks X is true we're
gonna go do why it's you have to have a
reason for it right and I think that's
the part that kind of gets lost and now
that it's being overused it's like
almost become cool you know a couple
years ago there's cool just to start a
company right but that was kind of the
tail end of that being cool
now all sudden you see people saying oh
is a narrative violation like
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's right right and I think that's a
really important piece of what you guys
have done is you've proven time and
again that you found something that
wasn't consensus and it continued to
work right you guys have kind of been
right in doing that yes I don't like the
non consensus and right framing so I
think that sort of the benchmark what
benchmark says so I'll let them own that
well you'll keep we'll keep narrative
violation over here you know our name
our name sounds similar bedrock
benchmark so we need some
differentiation from that and so I think
I think marks is the first one to say is
this a didn't like a I think this one
got 1992 I'll probably the year wrong
but I think he was of one of the first
people to say like look you gotta have
to do something different than everyone
else and be right he was talking about
it more like fixed income type stuff but
uh but the benchmark might have borrowed
that from interesting well I will I
think that I do think the sort of
incremental piece that hopefully is
somewhat generative for folks who do
sort of think about these narrative
violations is that I'm definitionally in
the term you sort of have to ask well
where do the narratives come from and
and more often than not that the most
dominant narratives come from come from
the media and so there's a there's a
sense in which if you actually are
pursuing investments that are that are
counter-narrative you actually want to
be looking for things that either the
media is not writing about they're not
talking about or oftentimes things that
they're they're critical of and and
that's sort of an additional lens that
you can apply as an investor to finding
these companies a narrative Mirage is
another part of this right so it's kind
of the narrative violation is the thing
that is different but also these
narrative mirages or the things
everyone's talking about that actually
may be incorrect I know you guys have
some thoughts here like around scooters
and things like that maybe talk a little
bit about how you think about the
narrative Mirage certainly so I'd say
one that that we've thought has been a
narrative Mirage for a while has
actually been the whole frenzy around
direct-to-consumer brands over the last
number of years and so you know we
founded bedrock in late 2017 we haven't
made a single direct to consumer brand
investment there's not a single one in
our portfolio and the reason why was
because you had the investors valuing
these businesses as technology
businesses when they're in fact they're
more like a Proctor and Gamble CPG
and so that's saying that we've argued
you know behind the scenes with folks in
our in our world we think a lot of these
d2c businesses are our narrative mirages
and and and and now just recently the
narratives very sharply turned against
them you only need one or two I'm gonna
get in the public market and get slam
the Casper I hear you have the brand les
bankruptcy and you know this all very
unfortunate stuff and these are great
founders it sucks it's happening the
Casper IPO the brand lists bankruptcy
you've got that the FTC stopping the
stopping that the Harry's acquisition I
mean that that must just be brutal if
you're you think you've sold your
company and now you know and and in fact
that says no no you go sort of go back
and got to go back and and and and may
and make it work I mean man so so in
fact there might actually be so what
that means is there might actually be
opportunities in direct to consumer
brands in the future and the valuations
are probably gonna get rationalized
because of these developments about
beating sound saying that was a
narrative Mirage you know we've we've
remained consistent that when we've
started the firm we launched it into we
launched it into two things the crypto
craze which I'm you know I think that is
gonna be long term right now and I think
we relied on that and this and the
scooter craze which we've which we've
been very very consistent on that we are
we are very skeptical of we think it's a
narrative Mirage and and and and it's
sort of this this market where it sort
of works particularly well on every
narrative layer and so if you sort of
unpack it you know you sort through all
these layers four narratives so you've
got founder you've got company you've
got market you know you've got Society
and so from a founder layer it's sort of
you know the founders of the scooter
companies generally worked at the
ride-sharing companies they were
generally at uber or lyft and in some
cases both so it's like okay sort of a
straight lines ride-sharing you know the
market sort of again straight line to
lyft and uber this is for short
distances last mile etc the you know
societally they're sort of good for the
world and so in a world where we're
talking a lot about climate change sort
of this you know nice scooters man nice
nice thought that we can all just ride
around on our electric scooters
it doesn't matter if it's you know yet
20 degrees outside and snowing or
raining or whatever we'll still just
ride the electric scooters everywhere
you know sort of inconvenient they don't
work when the weather is not weather's
not great they don't really work for you
on steep hills but we just ignore those
problems we've got this climate change
issues we can all ride our electric
scooters so there's a sense in which
when it's hyper good for society and you
can draw a straight line to this
category that has worked you get a lot
of frenzy and heat around it and then if
you actually really dig in to the
businesses as we as we have with with
one of them um it turns out that uh it
turns out that they're they're not
necessarily great businesses now that's
not to say that one or two of them is
not going to work to some degree and I'm
certainly I like the entrepreneurs I'm
rooting for them but uh but I think the
category is at this point definitively
was a narrative Mirage yeah and then
crypto where's the conviction they're
kind of what why so heavily convicted on
that given you guys are fairly critical
of other things that people are excited
about Rick said in 2017 there's a lot of
people excited about Krypton we didn't
do anything in 20 we did you guys start
to do things in crypto is that more like
18 bare market
I'm not gonna say exactly what we've
done but we yes we we we got involved in
crypto at a at a very at when at a
moment in time and it was very unpopular
to do anything in crypto that's all I'll
say now I'm not going to disclose
anymore day to day that's all you need
to say you guys recently announced the
Athletics I wanna talk about a couple of
the investors you guys made and some of
this we agree on some of it we don't
what's the logic behind the athletic
right and for those they don't know the
athletic is it's a Content business that
essentially said look we're gonna go
find the best reporters at local sports
reporters we're gonna pay them well
we're gonna give them kind of more
autonomy and we're going to wrap this up
into a subscription business that it's
like 10 bucks a month 60 bucks a year
and if you subscribe you now get access
to quote-unquote the best sports
reporting on the planet the business has
grown very nicely and then you guys just
made a pretty big investments what's the
thought process there cool see that's
another one where we've we've made a
number of investing
so we've scaled into it over three
separate financing rounds so we always
you know we always like to start with
the entrepreneurs and the founders and
so we've sort of rewind to - shortly
before we started bedrock my partner
Eric Stromberg I was at a Y Combinator
demo day I think it's the last YC demo
day we've attended we don't we don't
really go to those anymore but the last
YC demo day um and you know they're all
these presentations then after the demo
day you have all of the all the
investors sort of swarm the hot
companies and so Eric to his credit was
looking for other founders that weren't
being swarmed by investors you know the
two founders of the athletic Alex and
Adam we're sort of standing in the
corner not really know was talking to
them don't want to hear about the
business and it's um Eric went up and
started talking to them and almost made
a seed investment but but didn't
unfortunately it would have been a great
investment but kept in touch with them
built the relationship over a number of
years and because he'd been working on
Easter which was a subscription business
as well that wasn't a huge success
I was acquired by Google but wasn't a
huge financial success um had really
spent a lot of time thinking deeply
about the mechanics of what makes a
great subscription business like a
Netflix like what do you need to have
and there are a few things that he he
gained very high conviction that need to
be true and and by extension we at
bedrock sort of how to have an ethos
around the subscription one is you know
retention is is just everything and so
you want these sort of ultra high
retention businesses where you have very
low churn to as you need differentiated
proprietary content that you just sort
of can't get can't get it anywhere else
you need passionately loyal readers or
listeners who are passionately lower the
actual content creators and then you
need some sort of some sort of
winner-take-all dynamic on a market by
market level and so with the athletic
what's so interesting about sports is
you know in every any given market there
are a handful of teams or handful of
sports that people are really passionate
about there are a handful of writers
that sort of real people do passionately
follow and if you can actually by having
great retention through a paid
subscription pay these writers these
content creators more than anyone else
you can create this phenomenal flywheel
where you basically lock up these local
sports media monopolies with these great
writers you give them a platform to grow
their reach and the economics work
overtime because the retention of the
businesses is astronomical it's
something like 80% one-year attention
which is sort of well north of Netflix
well north of the Bible numbers never we
we spent like a month verifying the
numbers before we investors who sort of
really didn't believe them and then if
you retain for two years I think it's
sort of 95 percent of from year one to
year twenty year one to year two stick
around and so you know in the business
to date you know they've got over six
hundred thousand paying sobs the
business date has just been really
mostly just written content and so if
you think about all of the different
areas they can go to if they started
doing audio now start expanding into
Europe you I'd imagine they would do
video in the future um so it's sort of
this very there's a lot of ways in which
the business just continues to grow and
expand and then sports is sort of the
there's a sense in which it's and I
don't hope I don't get in trouble for
saying this and there's a sense in which
well I won't controlled by you but they
blew by it by somebody others a sense in
which it's kind of a an anti media media
company in that in that you know there
are a few of these legacy media company
media brands New York Times being one
they're gonna do fine going forward but
by and large local newspapers are really
kind of screwed and that the driver of
revenue for all of these local
newspapers has been the sports such and
that's what drives all of the ad revenue
um and and so the question is well
what's gonna replace all of these local
newspapers and you know we think it is
it is going to be the athletic yeah so
this is super interesting because uh my
father recently calls me and he goes hey
I went to go read an article in the
newspaper of a very rural area in North
Carolina like we're talking can't be
more than 20,000 people live in this
area
right and that's probably being overly
generous and they've got a newspaper and
they put up a pay wall and he said that
he goes he clicks on an article right
and he gets it with the pay wall and he
goes there is a feature where you can
pay ninety nine cents for the day right
because they literally have real
if you were not gonna be on a monthly
basis when today's want to read the one
article so we're gonna get there one
dollar and do it and he he knows nothing
about media knows you know any of this
stuff he just was laughing at the fact
that he's like there's no way that that
thing survives right and part of it is
the quality some of it is just like what
could possibly be going on there that
you can't get somewhere else right kind
of that idea of you had some content of
the people don't have but when you then
look at it and you say well if something
like the athletic comes and takes away
the need for me to check the scores
right and in kind of that component
there's really no reason for it
right and yeah maybe they right it's
about a local business or whatever but
but it changes the dynamic of this and
part of what I think to me so
interesting is not the business model
but you're using the same staff you're
actually going and taking their staff
and just putting it in this new model
right so you don't change the quality of
the content you just change in which the
format in which you get it and then you
add in all these other cities you know
all their best writers etc it becomes
pretty compelling pretty quickly very
more importantly than that it's really
fun it's just a really fun business and
and yeah it's a it's a it's a really fun
business to be involved with I know that
the team's having a ton of fun building
it and we think the long-term trajectory
looks more like a Netflix type business
what we'll see if we're right on a ten
year time horizon so this brings into
question kind of media in general and
before we started recording we were
talking about kind of these new media
models right so you see the barstool
sports you see the athletic things like
sub stack have come out there's morning
brew is a large email newsletter etc do
you guys kind of generally think that
the old media model outside of maybe the
New York Times and a couple of others
goes away and get to replace by somebody
new or is this more of there's
coexistence there's the old models that
work and then there's new models that
come along and kind of carve out a
different demographic how do you think
about that as a like a market dynamic
well you know I'd say you always want
sort of look to the past as a way to
sort of help predict the future and so
one of the ways in which we like to do
that is to sort of try and do these
counterfactual counterfactual thought
experiments and so I think when it comes
to the media
one could do a counterfactual experiment
of if social media had existed sixty
years ago would would we have all the
media institutions we have where they've
actually lost their credibility a long
time ago when sort of any one can fact
check an article when a you know CEOs
can sort of have their own audiences and
can can publish their own their own
thinking and to their own audiences and
the public can decide who's more
credible sort of the CEO or the the
media the journalists that really that
really changed the other thing there's
an interesting counterfactual thought
experiment you could do on the impact
social media has had and and certainly I
think it is uh it's really screwed up
the business models for the media
companies and so in practice what that
means is I think we're now entering
we're already in it but I think people
are trying to key into we're in a realm
where really what matters is reach trust
and and and and your own differentiated
sort of point of view and so I'm pretty
convinced that we're entering it medias
again just be increasingly decentralized
and you know I may be in a hundred years
the New York Times is not even going to
exist at you know sort of a sort of a
they've they've often been critical of
companies like Facebook for having a you
know dual class share structure and and
which will enable mark to run it forever
and you know Salzburger also has the
dual class share structure the New York
Times he gets they got to run it forever
but there forever might not might not be
forever cuz I think that the ecosystem
is really really disrupted and so yeah I
think it's it's a it's a totally new era
and I think that journalists are
starting to realize it and there are a
lot of great journalists out there and I
think the really smart ones will do
things like what Jessica's building with
the information in the tech industry
with the Athletics doing with sports
we're talking really about things like
sub stock the enable journalists to just
build their own build their own business
on on a platform that gives them the
tools needed to to do it and I really do
think we're heading in that direction
and then one of the other great
developments I think is that the folks
that are written about actually are able
to tell their side of the story and so
you know you how I feel like the FedEx
see
there was an article about FedEx in the
Wall Street Journal the FedEx felt it
was a very inaccurate and the FedEx CEO
I was able to sort of write a letter and
get it distributed I think many more
people read the letter from from from
the CEO then then read the actual Wall
Street Journal article he challenged
them to a debate right yeah I don't
think they took him up on it no it's not
worse not because they knew they would
lose and you know I think you got we had
Dalio do this recently there was a New
York Times piece that he felt was was
very unfair you know he's got millions
of LinkedIn followers he wrote a
response on LinkedIn and I think
increasingly that's the world that we're
rendering and I don't think that that
the media industry is is ready for it so
I'm quite worried about them well and I
think part of this is social media
really has exposed the fact that these
big journalistic institutions are run by
humans right I mean ultimately what ends
up happening is journalists for a very
long time hid behind the fact of you
know we are very objective we don't have
bias we don't have a motion we have no
kind of horse in this race we just write
the facts and that pretty much was
accepted right I think a lot of people
if you go back in 20 30 years we were
like yeah but that's true and they read
whatever's in the Wall Street Journal
New York Times etc now all of a sudden
even before kind of the CEOs and
politicians etc realize that they could
do this you just started to get kind of
data points that would get you know
presented that all said wait a minute
that doesn't jive with what was written
right and so that kind of started people
questioning things what you're talking
about now is the ability of these
platforms to just completely remove that
middleman in telling the story right so
whether it's the FedEx you know I mean
look if you take in politics you've got
Trump and you've got a OC they both do
the same thing on two different sides of
the aisle they just draw as if I talk
directly to people
no one can mix my works right this is
what I want to say and so what it does
though is it then brings into question
at what point do we empower the people
being written about too much right if
all of a sudden people now just listen
to you know the FedEx CEO or some other
leader like who's there to fact-check
right it's kind of the the
counterbalance to this because the media
does serve a great purpose in a lot of
people who are full of [ __ ] right and
they do a great job of saying
no you're full of [ __ ] here's the truth
and so I that's my fear right it's like
the writing's on the wall and kind of we
know where we're going but what's that
counterbalance to kind of keep
optimizing for truth because I think
it's possible to not just rotate back to
the middle but actually over-rotate in
in favor of the people who were being
written about and now they can just
[ __ ] and kind of people just have to
take them at face value a hundred
percent I agree with use a massive a
massive risk and something I'm very
concerned about as well um you know my
hope and this sort of the optimistic
version would be that uh the the folks
that do fact-check and and public
publish truthful articles and can build
their own businesses on platforms like
subsets were talking about 20-year time
horizon I'm hopeful that there will be
trusted new brands and media that are
trusted to be a source of truth I think
the unfortunate reality of what's
happened is you've had these
historically trusted media brands that
have oftentimes published articles that
are not wholly truthful and so you can't
both be the arbiter of truth while also
publishing things that that aren't
truthful not I would also know that not
every highly regarded media institution
actually has fact checkers and so on one
interesting one interesting tidbit I
learned about the New York Times from
from some friends is they don't actually
have fact checkers on staff the
journalists check the fact check their
own articles and so I am all for fact
checkers I would be very supportive of
of every every media company doing
extensive fact-checking the reality is
that does not happen today I'm hopeful
that in a more decentralized media
environment as this continues to develop
actually we can get more fact-checking
they'll be people more in power to
actually fact check so I've got another
framework that this isn't fully fleshed
out yet but I've just started to realize
so if you look on a geographic basis the
Great Firewall in China has kept you
know a billion plus people in the dark
about what's going on in the rest of the
world right to some degree and either
they have no clue something happens or
they get pieces of the information but
it's stitched together in a story that
the government wants them to hear right
the coronavirus is the first time that's
been reversed we're now all of a sudden
the rest of the world is like what the
hell is going on in China and we either
don't know
or we're getting pieces of information
that are being strung together and we're
being told a story that they want us to
hear and it's really interesting because
I don't think a lot of people have
realized yet like this is the everyday
life of people in China with the rest of
the world when you reverse that now all
of a sudden everyone's up in arms like
you have to tell us you know it's like
we're we're the police of the world
right but that is a really dangerous
world to enter into where if this was
not just a China thing this was in
multiple places in the world whether
vertical based in terms of Industry or
Geographic based if you now start to get
fed stories where you can't fact check
you can't you actually get access to
information like that's a scary world to
live yes I've never been to China and
have no plans on going I think would be
a very scary place to be living
particularly now and I feel absolutely
horrible for the for the people there
but where are you going with this
because you have this where's this
theory take us let's let's drive on this
for a moment
so my whole thought process is you have
a country that's got 1.2 1.3 billion
people right yeah and it's becoming more
and more important to the world and the
coronavirus is like something that grabs
everyone's attention because there's
kind of the fear mongering aspect of it
it's health-related there's people dying
right all all that kind of stuff it
might actually be really really bad I
don't downplay what I mean is it's easy
to grab people's attention even if the
deaths aren't happening in the United
States right it's just the fact that
death grabs it yes but if you pull it to
less important things like technology
investing businesses you know all those
kind of stuff there was a wave in like
the nineties and into the 2000s carson
block and some of these guys like
realize hey we're being fed [ __ ]
right these companies are actually
frauds and they brought them down but
now all of a sudden there's like this
resurgence of you know china is getting
its act together except for the there's
a belief that like maybe we just are
being fed the rose colored glass
perspective right and maybe it's not
actually what we think it is and then if
that's happening in china to the rest of
the world like could that actually be
happening in the u.s. right you know
it's um one of the things that and i
forget the exact data
I think it's the Federal Reserve has
missed on GDP projections every single
time they've ever estimated right
they're like Oh for like 250 times or
something yeah which is [ __ ] crazy
right they're like at some point just
flip a coin you know right and you these
get closed but then you start to look at
now we also see things where like
numbers get reported and all of this
financial activity happens investment
stocks go you know up down sideways
whatever but then they go back and they
recalibrate the numbers you know a
quarter later or two quarters later but
everyone talks about it and so when you
start to like unpack some of this stuff
it's almost like is that intentional or
is it just really hard to count you know
in a highly complex environment and so
it leads to this idea that I start to
just think around like you literally
have to [ __ ] question everything
correct right and like that's not a
world I think that most people are one
well positioned to do like we actually
don't have the skills as Express in the
United Sates the the skills to question
everything because we're so used to just
accepting information that we're given
but also to if you question everything
and you start to get answers you don't
like I think that that quickly jumps off
a cliff that people just aren't thinking
about aren't ready for etc and this is
everything from the Jeffrey Epstein type
stuff all the way to you know literally
what's going on with the ground me
people have died like that that should
be pretty easy to measure right but
there's numbers I've literally seen 10x
in variation of numbers like that's big
[ __ ] you know spectrum all the way to
like did a dude get killed or did he
commit suicide in a government facility
right that had never had any never had
no one had ever died in that facility
before by the way like I'm always if
plane was here she would immediately be
like hey stop doing the conspiracy
theories right put my scary dangerous
yeah but it's not so much conspiracy
theory says it's pulling back on this
thread of like if we have to question
everything because the information we're
being fed is questionable where is the
line and I think what we're realizing is
like there is no line right it's not
just economic data it's not you know
information and stocks whatever it's
actually like a lot of different types
of information
and so when you take away the trust and
information like I don't think we've had
that before so like where does that take
us I don't know it's it's yeah I don't
think there's any way to predict where
it takes us
I think the the lesson is or at least
the the realization is we should have
been questioning everything all along
and so certainly that that should really
sink in for folks that one one should
have been questioning things for all the
previous that the boomers should have
questioned things
Gen X should have questioned things a
lot more than they did and and I so I'm
optimistic that the fact that more and
more people are keying into the fact
that I actually need to form your own
view of reality you need to question
what you're being told come up with your
own answers hopefully will be positive
now the challenge is just if you
question every issue that's out there
there are millions of different issues
at any any moment in time it's and
sloping right and so we're you know the
future is gonna favor people who are
able to actually very quickly sift out
and filter out anything that's not
relevant to like what they're trying to
do in the world and their their family
their loved ones what they're trying to
build what they're trying to do their
company and be able to really key in on
okay what are the like very important
things that I need to get to a truthful
view or view that I believe on and and
and and really really dig deep and and
review a lot of different sources and
and come to your own come to your own
view and so I think with individual
processing power and ability to filter
filter out things that aren't important
key and on the things that are question
them and get to your own view yeah I
think that is just table stakes for for
existing as sort of a sovereign
individual in today's world and and I
don't know where it's gonna lead us yeah
and so I want to make sure that I
clarify like I'm not suggesting that
everyone's lying about everything right
there's plenty of people who actually
just make mistakes and one of the things
that you guys have
I don't think counting is that hard
though on the numbers thing that's
really right so like this that's where
you get into kind of the narrative
Mirage if you will but but one of the
things you guys have said going back to
kind of more investing in
entrepreneurship is like the media
forgets a lot of times that founders are
human and humans make mistakes
and that doesn't mean that if you make a
mistake like we shouldn't call you on it
we shouldn't say anything bad but like
there is this element of like it's okay
to make a mistake right and so how do
you guys think about that internally and
not even so much with your aportfolio
come it's just more of like tech was
really good for a number of years and
then it became like the bad people right
and I go let's all go yell at these
people they're there they're being too
successful right so like let's go attack
them where's the line or like what's the
framework to think through like when is
it nope they did something bad versus
they made a mistake and they should be
able to kind of overcome that or or at
least make it right at some point it's
always case specific so you know
whenever there's a thing thing that's
hyper case specific you always want to
try and come up with some sort of
shortcut type formula and on this
specific question of sort of you know I
guess we call it cancelling founders
sort of a terminology and culture the
cancel cultures it relates sort of these
entrepreneurs and and certainly there
are you know there's certainly people in
the world who should be you know who
really have deserved have been cancelled
they probably deserved it and then I
think they're probably a lot more who
who probably haven't and so if you sort
of so I'm gonna start with a metaphor
and then I want to get into a sort of
shortcut rule that maybe there are a few
exceptions too so the metaphor would be
if you commit a crime let's say you
assault someone which I know you haven't
done but if some theorem Norv I but
theoretically if someone assaulted
someone they were arrested it jury trial
you know you would go to jail you would
serve your sentence and then I think
most people would agree that once you're
released from jail and you've served
your time you should be able to
reintegrate back into society and live a
life and and sort of have an existence
and I think that's if you're let out of
jail you sort of get to start again and
you get a second chance there is no
equivalent for canceled culture and so
if you're cancelled your life's
permanently ruined and it doesn't matter
why you were cancelled it's just your
life's over
and and no one wants to talk to you
anymore and you can't do anything else
and so it strikes me as really bizarre
that there's a second chance for
ex-convicts but not for people that have
been can't so that seems really screwed
up to me something I'd love some sort of
you know get out of jail option once
you've been cancelled unfortunate I
don't quite know what that is
then I'd say the shortcut on this is you
know one of the great I've learned you
know so many things from Peter Thiel one
of the great things I learned from him
was that when you're evaluating the
business model of a company these
laundry lists type business models works
like what we can monetize your
advertising through subscription through
selling the data when there's a laundry
list of different business models it
actually means
there's just no business model and the
company doesn't know how to make money
and I actually increasingly think this
laundry list analogy can apply to the
canceled culture stuff as well and so
I'm very skeptical when there's sort of
a list of accusations that aren't all
the same thing and so if someone's been
accused of you know doing the same thing
over and over again like that that's bad
probably bad but you know in the case of
something like a way where you had the
board try and cancel or the media tried
to cancel Steph quarry the CEO she's the
CEO of the company she's now back it was
sort of this laundry list of mean things
she'd said onslaught and so it's like
well she said this mean thing and then
she also she also said this really mean
thing and and then there's this other
mean thing and it was sort of a list of
of mean things that she said and that
made me some very skeptical of that as a
cancellation now she's now back so
that's a really positive development if
you rewind to when Travis was canceled
from uber and to be clear disclosed my
bias upfront I am NOT a natural ally of
uber or Travis lyft and was literally on
the board yeah it was basically it was
yes he cost me a lot of emotional trauma
on the lift he was a formidable
competitor that you talked about earlier
yes Travis
everyone get was actually try Travis and
I think Emil was pretty good too but you
never wanna compete compete against he
doesn't but in any case you know the the
retrospectively if you look back at the
the series of facts that led to him
being ousted from uber it was it had a
very laundry list feel to it was sort of
like well he was sort of was mean to
this driver yeah he was really stupid he
shouldn't have said that it was
offensive but you know I don't think it
warrants being canceled from your
company you know it was like yep there
was a there was this culture of weird
sexual harassment stuff he wasn't
directly implicated in any of that no
one tied anything back to him they're
sort of uh you know um you know there
was sort of other random accusations but
it had very much a laundry list feel to
it and so whenever there's a laundry
list of accusations I'm I'm very
skeptical of it ah and and then in
certain cases it's justified so
certainly you know someone like
Elizabeth Holmes you know I think that
would that was I'm really glad that that
that story came out and I think that was
very positive for the world and and and
was a positive development and so it's
always case specific but uh but I am
very skeptical of the of the laundry
lists a and B it strikes me as really
screwed up that it's sort of worse than
going to jail if you're cancelled well
and go back to your metaphor about kind
of there's a bad thing that happens then
there's a trial then there's jail then
there's like restart race the cancel
culture has like maybe bad thing that
happened and there's no trial by your
peers it's usually trial by somebody
with bias or a Twitter mob so Twitter
mob or or the media or whatever and then
very quickly because people are looking
for this stuff it snowballs right that's
where you get kind of mob mentality but
the two things that it doesn't have is
like actual confirmation like did that
happen or did it not did it happen in
the way that it was said is it actually
as bad as it like the away stuff
literally I think part of the reason why
the CEO came back was because there was
actually bunch of people saying like
what are you talking about like that's
not that bad right so like yes she said
it but it's actually not that bad
writing and that's what you get in a
traditional trial somebody does
something bad you know crime or whatever
but then the other piece is like there's
no sentence right I think this is what
you're getting at where it's it's one
thing to hey you can't restart but I
actually think it's because there's no
sentence so in the criminal action
there's you're convicted and then you
are sentenced in that sentence is a very
specific thing you aren't going to jail
so you're gonna go sit in this cell for
three years when you get out your time
is done right it's like when you put a
kid in timeout right you're gonna sit
there for five minutes when you're done
it's over move on in cancel culture
there's no sentence and therefore if
there's no sentence you get in a world
where
like everyone has their own idea of the
sentence right it's you know that person
should not be allowed to ever
participate in building a company ever
again
if you sit out for a year then okay
you've kind of served your time quote
unquote you should be able to come back
and everything in between if you don't
have the sentence you can't get the
restart right and so like it's not a
crime so you can't use like the legal
system but I agree with you that that is
a missing component which prevents
people from being able to restart unless
you're somebody like a Travis who
literally just says I'm gonna solve my
uber stock I'm gonna take my money i'ma
go build another company and like good
luck try and compete with me right I
think that's the only thing you can do
because if you don't have that
sentencing component you know if you and
I disagree on how long that person
should be punished then there's no right
answer that's right but I will say that
I think the tides are turning so there's
a few a few few cautiously optimistic
signs here so I'd say one I think the
staff quarry case with away was a case
where she sort of she fought back and
she she she sort of won the fight and so
I think the lesson one can take away
from that is if people are trying to
cancel you and you and you as an
individual one as an individual doesn't
believe that the grounds are valid you
need to fight back and you need to get
your allies to fight back with you and
so sort of fighting back against the the
castle culture I think we now have a
data point at least in a tech
entrepreneur concept that it actually
can work moreover I think you know
people in powerful positions are
starting to key in to the fact that
actually often times it's quite unfair
and so perhaps patient zero for sort of
the Twitter cancellation in sort of cap
tech adjacent industry would have been
like do you remember justine sacco she'd
been that she was an IAC she was a PR
person at IAC she was all going on a
long flight to South Africa oh she
tweeted a sort of very off-color you
know it's not a joke that I would ever
tweet it was obviously really bad
judgment sort of off-color joke and was
just she'd been on who's on this 14-hour
flight or something she lands and checks
her Twitter was fired and it was like
literally retweeted a hundred thousand
times or something and mobs came after
she was fired
she was from I see she was just rehired
by match which is an IAC company to lead
up leave their PR now it was sort of
like a you know 9 or 10 years of
basically having to live in purgatory
but uh but she's been brought back to
the company that you know a subsidiary
of the company that fired her and so I
do have hope that that this is actually
some starting to change and and and it's
just up to everyone it's up to all of us
to you know sometimes it's valid and and
then we have to really question we have
to really question every case is it as a
unique sort of situation and people who
are being cancelled need a fight back
they think it's unfair
yeah and and part of where this gets to
like a really slippery slope is it's one
thing for you and I as adults like we
have brains that are fully developed
right we can make our own decisions
hopefully we are smart enough to not do
dumb [ __ ] right and all this kind of
stuff but if you take a 16 17 18 year
old kid right I mean how many kids have
the story that really blew me away was
uh there were some kids I think a couple
of them got accepted to it was like
Harvard or something and then I don't
remember in all of the details but I
think they had either racist tweets or
something like that that came back and
actually got their scholarships revoked
or their admission revoked right now
guess what
racist is really bad right and they
should not have said that except but how
many sixteen-year-old kids across the
country of all races have said something
whether they were joking or not right
well it was just that social social
media wasn't around to document it right
and so like there's a whole generation
of kids that are now growing up where
they're frankly they're immature right
their brains aren't developed like there
is some question of if we are going to
document everything everyone does where
is the line and the the sad part is like
I actually don't know right if I was
sitting there as that administrator at
Harvard or whatever the school was and
how to make that decision I don't
remember all the facts right but like I
don't know how I would think about that
I even know if I have a framework to
think through that and so the cancel
culture affecting adults who make adult
decisions later in their career like
that's one whole bucket there's a whole
nother bucket for essentially kids right
how many kids are putting dumb stuff on
tick-tock right now and is gonna surface
it you know five years from now and they
get fired from their job they don't get
accepted to a school whatever like is
that fair I don't know
right but like that that's
all another component of this that I
think just isn't part of the mainstream
conversation but will eventually have to
be entered into that conversation
because it's a reality of the day of the
world we're living yes
and I would argue that this whole the
cancel culture stuff is sort of an
outgrowth of sort of the woke movement
and there's a sense in which even think
about sort of whoa chasm as a religion
just as Christianity is a religion now
I'm not Christian but I do know that
Christianity provides for people people
are sinners and they make mistakes you
can sort of repent for your sins and and
and you can still be a good person and
and that doesn't exist in woke ISM so if
you sort of if you if you if you screw
up and are cancelled other isn't a
second chance so certainly in the
children context that's that's very
dangerous if you sort of think about who
the teachers in the schools are you know
think tend to be somewhat in public
institutions many of these leading
universities and and and private schools
etc it's there's a sense in which local
ISM is kind of becoming the religion and
I think there's some very valid
attributes to it but at the same time
they're it's a it is it is sort of a a
very rigid religion and and and and we
don't have any sense of what the what
the long-term consequences are gonna be
yeah I think you and I agree on on the
idea of like the world tries to make
things black and white and it's just not
black and white that's right and and so
it's like case-specific it's very grey
and and we have to be aware of what's
happening because it affects everybody
in all these different ways and if you
don't talk about kind of what's
happening then you know it just runs
wild frankly moving on another thing you
guys think of a lot about and I've seen
you tweeting about is growth valuations
being heavily heavily overvalued
that's not very popular opinion many
circles where is that coming from the
kind of how do you think about that sure
so you know look here's the reality of
what's happened so you sort of got it's
it's very hard to get a return on on
one's capital today in this environment
so it's sort of like well how are you
gonna get return on your money and sort
of up one one sort of place where over
the last number of years
been able to generate a good return has
been in venture capital and in
particular you know grouse stage and and
and some summer cents TV so what you've
seen is over the last seven eight years
tons of capital hundreds of billions of
dollars have flown into the asset class
they're like hundreds of new funds that
are getting they're getting formed every
you know every every few months or so
and basically in order to like scale up
a venture fund from having a few hundred
million dollars to having billions of
dollars under management you actually
have to you have to actually deploy the
capital you actually have to invite
invest invested in things and so you
actually have this weird adverse
incentive where you have these firms
that are trisha - scale their assets
under management such that they they're
investing in companies at valuations
that are pretty crazy and Softbank was
sort of the the modal example and and
and and i think that you know maybe had
had somewhat of an impact there
obviously good growth stage companies
but but yeah i do think they're
generally generally pretty overvalued
and sort of the the broader the broader
point that i'd make is a lot of the
things that we call tech we've called
tech companies over the past few years
aren't actually tech companies and so
certainly a lot of the FinTech stuff and
I am I am pretty bullish on FinTech I
sort of led the series see a new bank
Founders Fund we've done a lot of
FinTech investing it at bedrock but a
lot of the FinTech companies their
product is just money and if you're
selling money that's not really a tech
company that should this should weren't
a tech valuation you know same thing can
be said for the the d2c brands you know
we work was not a tech company they
tried to put sort of a technology gloss
over it and and and and these businesses
been able to command these tech
valuations at the growth stage because
you have so much capital in the venture
asset class that that is looking to get
deployed you know the other sort of
perverse way in which this manifest says
one thing that sort of people generally
understand in venture capitalists there
are actually only a few dozen really
good venture capitalists that have sort
of generated the vast majority of the
return so I became a VC in 2012 I think
at the time they're sort of you know 10
or 11 who I thought were really good at
this point there's
maybe 30 who I think are sort of really
good investors have generated the
majority of the returns for their firms
but uh there's only so many
opportunities that's right so many
opportunities there's only some people
that are actually that are actually good
at this and yet to actually scale up the
assets under management at a firm you
have to scale the team and so basically
what we've seen happen is these teams
just become huge in fact friend of mine
is a great investor she's a partner at a
very large VC firm and I think they have
saying like 20-30 partners and I was
looking at their website the other day
and going through the partners and I
think only three of the 20 plus partners
have really ever made any investments
and so there's all these managing
partners that haven't actually made any
investments but the firm manages you
know billions and billions and billions
of dollars and I think that actually you
just yeah you need to hire these people
so that you can raise the money but of
course of course you can't actually let
them invest that because that would ruin
the strategy sort of like art pieces
hanging on the wall and so I would sort
of encourage encourage anyone
considering becoming a VC are you going
to be a an art piece on the wall to help
the firm raise more money or gonna
actually be able to invest because
that's the only way to learn how to do
this yeah and this leads into you said a
bunch of times like the overhype
component of like becoming a VC early in
your career right it used to be a thing
where hey go be an entrepreneur have a
successful exit get some money then go
decide you want to be a investor kind of
that later in your career and and then
at that point like you've almost earned
the right to do this now I mean there's
literally kids that are and you know
early years of college saying my goal is
to be a VC right like right out of
school I want to go work at a venture
firm how do you think about like what's
too early what's not is it a
case-by-case thing like what's kind of
the thought process if you're talking to
a young kid about who wants to go do
that yeah look it's always case-by-case
so I mean in order to be successful as a
VC a you need to be able to make
investments so everyone we hire on the
investment team at bedrock is empowered
to make investments so that's sort of
part ones thing if you're a young person
looking to be a VC you should join a
firm will you will be allowed to make
invest
so that's sort of the gating factor and
then I think to be successful as an
investor you need three things you need
access to great companies you need to
pick the companies correctly and you
need to you need to win win the deal and
then yeah of course you also need to be
right over overtime if you're sort of a
young person coming out of college uh
it's very unlikely that you're gonna
have great intuitions on what businesses
are gonna really work it's very unlikely
you're gonna have sort of differentiated
access to companies it's very unlikely
you're gonna be able to win the deal and
so I think and practice a lot of young
folks can spend years and years in VC
supporting you know senior partners
never making any investments you might
end up getting a title as sort of a
managing director like you know a lot of
these folks at my friend's firm and
spend eight plus years there and never
actually make an investment but that's
not a very fulfilling very fulfilling
career I mean what we love what gives us
energy at bedrock every day is we get to
spend all day meeting with brilliant
founders deciding whether we want to
invest in something all over the world
I'm all different industries all
different sectors that's really exciting
I think running spreadsheets and and and
writing market research reports for a
sort of you know random managing
director not a very exciting career path
I'd be part one I'd say part two of why
I'm sort of skeptical of it is because
it's become the hot thing to do um
definitionally it's it's probably quite
overhyped and then finally um there is a
sense in which it's a pretty comfortable
thing to do and so you sort of start
doing it it's very comfortable um you
know a lot of folks don't work very hard
for VCS that's not true of everyone
certainly we we like working and we work
very hard but not everyone does so it
gets really comfortable but the lessons
you learn as a venture investor they
actually aren't really applicable to too
many other things and so you're not
gonna learn how to operate a company if
you're if you're a VC you're not gonna
learn how to code a piece of software if
you're a VC you're not at most firms
you're not really gonna learn about
things we're talking about earlier like
how to how to question narratives and
how to actually that's not what most VC
firms will teach you now there are a few
exceptions you know there
place Lagos and founder some exceptions
to this but I think generally it's it's
it's a suboptimal track for most folks
unless you join bedrock in you talked
about like as an investor and I've
always felt this way of like the job of
smart people or it's usually some of the
smart people in the industry coming in
and then teaching you about something is
pretty [ __ ] incredible right in that
interaction I saw you tweet and say that
there's some people who say to founders
don't argue with the investor right like
basically go in pitch I'm like don't get
in an argument you took the opposite
track which I actually agree with it's
narrow that's part of the fun of the
pitch right is wait a minute I'm calling
[ __ ] on this or I don't understand
this and the back-and-forth Conte's is
out more information why why do you
think other people say don't argue and
then kind of how do you guys use that
debate or lively discussion to your
advantage of other people aren't gonna
do it huh interesting I want to speak
for the other people but I will say for
us is you know through getting into a
spirited debate you actually can get to
the truth about about different things
and so you can push back on elements of
the pitch as an investor and hear how
the founder responds then you sort of
unpack the answers and you ask follow-up
questions it's a way to actually get to
the truth a be a cue a conversation or a
three four five way conversation is much
more fun than just having someone talk
at you and you know one of the things
that I think is just true in one's
career is you want to optimize for
having a lot of fun and so if you're
doing something you're not having fun
that doesn't make any sense it's
certainly just a purely selfish reasons
we find it fun to debate we like
debating with founders we like being
proven wrong we like hearing better
arguments than then on our point of view
and we can oftentimes get convinced I
mean founders have convinced me of
opportunities I thought were crap
through getting into these spirited
debates and actually getting me to
change my position I think you know the
a key marker of someone who's sort of
curious and intelligent is like you're
able to change your mind if someone
makes a compelling argument
and a shocking idea in today's society
like that's called flip-flopping you
can't do that right
why mandatory I'm a notorious flip-flop
but it goes back to this idea of like
intellectual honesty right then if you
are actually intellectually honest with
yourself the things that you actually
have high conviction on and are willing
to like argue to the death there's very
very few of them right and if you are
presented with new information why would
you not change your mind
right it's almost like you flip and
you're like wait a minute you're an
idiot if you don't change your mind if
you're giving you information that
proves your previous thought process was
probably not accurate yes now that is
true certainly in a pitch context you
have to be careful about changing your
mind too often once you've made an
investment so this is one failure mode
that I've actually been guilty of in the
past where sort of make an investment
there's a period of time where things
don't go very well and it's very easy to
just skew hyper- and this is sort of I
think a lot of the psychology around
Bitcoin as well as you know people
decide called you can just shift very
dramatically from positive to negative
and so you need to actually just have a
very you do need to have high conviction
the long term trajectory of a company
you invest in and and and then you just
have to be you as the facts change you
take them into account but generally I
think you want you know moderate
opinions strongly held once you're an
investor and you want you want strong
opinions weakly held before you invest
the first time we met in person we had a
great conversation and when I was
walking out the door you said something
I said I forgot whatever it was and I
was a guy I just got lucky and you
immediately snapped back with there's no
such thing as luck and it's something
that I actually feel very strongly about
this and I agree with your sentiment but
it's not socially acceptable to say that
oh this is a tricky one to unpack so
first of all whenever I say there's no
such thing as luck it's always
off-the-record so who takes lays off
their dad's out on the record that's a
gimme good we're gonna roll with X it's
now on the record so my off the records
of the and again you know
this is off the record
never say that on the record but in any
case I did say it to you off the record
and it was in a specific context and
basically here's here's here's what I
think about Locke so I think you need to
look at it sort of through a
sociological lens so basically my my
current view of it is um that people who
are people who are not successful people
who have not been able to achieve what
they want in life ascribe everything to
Locke that's incorrect so it's like oh
it's all just luck and I'm an unlucky
person okay I think there's people who
who are successful but don't feel that
they they are that they are fully
successful or fully made it sort of like
a chip off one's shoulder type type vibe
in which case in which case also there's
no luck there's no such that I think
that's there's no such thing of law as
luck and I think both you and I are
people who are who are very ambitious
and and so I think it's a healthy
mentality I think it's even if there is
such a thing as luck which I do believe
there is to be clear on the record I
think the right healthy mentality as
you're as you're building something if
you're very ambitious you're trying to
make real impact on the world is to have
the mentality at least that you make
your own luck there's not some sort of
preordained a magical a lottery ticket
that's gonna this gonna this gonna fall
on your lap and then I think that
actually the the best the people have
really made it and who and who are sort
of clear-eyed about it I would
acknowledge that luck does play some
role and so so the way I think about
this is pre being born post being born
okay right and pre being born there's a
lot of things a lot of luck that goes
into right kind of the ovarian lottery
right and so where you're born what
language you speak the color of your
skin the the socio-economic situation
you're born into it there that's all
luck right in terms of yeah there's some
math probability but but it's luck
you're given a deck of cards it's kind
of how I think about it once you're
given the deck of cards from there
there's very little if no luck
and it being the things that are outside
of your control all happened pretty much
before you're born right and I think
that when people would take this
paintbrush and say no luck all luck
right whatever again it doesn't kind of
account for no you and I and many people
assuming this are super super lucky
because most people who are listening to
any kind of audio content right totally
naturally are in a way better position
in life than majority of the humans on
this planet so there's kind of a here's
your starting point whether it's good
bad or or in between but then from there
there's very specific things that occur
right on ways people who believes that
even when it's not in your control so
like the the family environment right
somebody's making decisions that isn't
quote unquote lock right it's somebody
somewhere is making a decision that then
puts you in that situation and what you
do with it ends up being the actions you
take and so it's it's almost like this
taboo thing where luck gets again that
paintbrush but if you look at it that
way now all of a sudden like you said
it's kind of this mentality component
but also it changes behavior right and I
think that's the key piece of it where
there's a lot of people who sit around
and when they have the mentality of luck
luck luck luck luck the action fall or
the lack of action usually yes right
whereas if you go into it with the
mentality of there is no luck I had luck
to be the starting place I was now there
is no luck it's all on whether I
accomplished something or not the action
does follow and there's this great book
that I used to keep it as a secret and
not tell people about this book that was
like oh this is a [ __ ] advantage in
life but now lately I started to tell a
lot of people about it so in 2013 this
guy Tim Grover wrote a book called
relentless okay Tim Grover is a dude he
played college basketball got hurt says
you know what rather than be a
basketball player in the NBA I'm not
gonna make it I want to train those guys
and so one of his first clients ever was
he went to the Chicago Bulls and he
called every single player other than
Michael Jordan and he said well guys the
best in the world so he doesn't need me
I'll call everybody
long story short he becomes Michael
Jordan's trainer and he gets a chance
the Chicago Bulls staff says you can
come and he'll work for with you for
like 30 or 90 days some short period of
time and in the first meeting Jordans
basically like you know who the [ __ ] are
you right you know I'm best player in
the world what are you gonna do for me
lays out an exact plan and they end up
working together for 20 years right he
then becomes the trainer to Kobe Bryant
Dwyane Wade like every single top NBA
player in the world goes to this guy and
some of them are every week they work
with them some of them are don't talk to
him for three years I need you right now
fly to where I am and like help me for
two days type thing and in the book he
lays out there's three types of people
there's uh I think a clean I think he
calls at a cooler a closer and a cleaner
and he goes a cooler is just somebody
who is basically happy to be there right
they're happy to be in the NBA it's
great if we're towards the end of the
game tell me the play coach and you know
I'll go try my best and where's the
party at after the game type attitude a
closer is somebody who says hey coach
give me the ball and if I'm open I'm
gonna shoot if you're open I'll pass you
the ball right but a cleaner he's like
is going to [ __ ] take the shot right
no matter what they're gonna create the
situation they're gonna take the shot
they're going to win the game and
there's no question nobody in that
huddle is questioning it etc and when he
goes on to talk about is those are also
the guys at during the offseason who
realized practice should be harder than
the games right it's not that oh
practice let's go take some shots and
then go home and like I'll turn it on
for the game no I'm gonna actually work
harder in practice than I do in the game
so the game's easy and he goes through
this idea and it's used as a term
cleaners but the whole thing is around
everyone else thinks oh he turned it on
for the game he got lucky in the game
the ball bounced his way this time like
all of those kind of sports metaphors
that are used although are associated
with this idea of luck right and he
doesn't talk about luck in the thing but
it's basically sorry mom but he was
there's very select few cleaners that
when they walk in the gym everyone knows
that's a cleaner and that person's here
and no matter what happens in this game
they're in control and I think that
applying that type of attitude
the rest of life completely changes the
actions that people take and that's
where like this idea of like quote
unquote there's no luck when you apply
in that framework all of a sudden it's
like well yeah I do [ __ ] believe that
it's a very it's a very healthy very
healthy frame of mind to have and back
to your just deck of cards metaphor it's
it's about how you play the hand you're
dealt yeah yeah I think it's a great way
to look at it what are you excited about
kind of moving forward in in the tech
role what what is one or two areas where
you're like no one's talking about it
but we think that there's you know
incredible opportunity there yeah and I
never I always always refuse to answer
this I was refused to answer this
question about why do you refuse well
you always want refuse to answer the
question because if it's an area that if
it's an area that if it's an area that
we're excited about definitionally we
haven't found the right company doing to
invest in yeah and so you know here
here's some thoughts one I do think
there is a lot more on the sort of
enabling infrastructure side of things
you just had the plot acquisition by
Visa stripe as a phenomenal company we
think there's more like that that that
that these can be very valuable
companies are sort of enabling
infrastructure in infant Akron in other
areas can be very very valuable um you
know I'd say to is I do think there will
be a new wave of consumer consumer
internet applications and I think most
people have just said consumers dead all
the energy all of the heat is on
enterprise SAS those are the best to be
clear those are the businesses today
that are working they are mostly
enterprise SAS businesses and we have a
number of investments there but I just
think for a lot of the a lot of the
consumer internet applications are
somewhat broke and there's got to be a
new wave and it it might actually just
take to centralization to make it happen
so it might be ten years away but I'm
optimistic on that and then there's
always the question of what can you do
on the on the biotech side of things to
sort of make people healthier and
certainly with coronavirus there's a
heightened heightened interest on my end
in in in in in that whole world um but
in practice the companies end up not
actually being that
you ball and so it's sort of like you
get to a certain milestone you sell to a
pharmaceutical company so the question
of is there some way these companies can
get more valuable so there were a few
things that old problem like the access
to capital is just not there for them to
scale past and they have to sell or
write what you think it's sort of like
it's it's very hard to build a build a
build a plot a drug platform it sort of
everyone everyone pitches that and then
in practice it's it's really hard to
actually do um yeah I think it is a you
know somewhat of an access to capital
problem and I think it's also in many
cases a founder mentality type problem
and so there aren't that many founders
that have sort of a internet software
Silicon Valley type type mentality to
building building a biotechnology
business so if you find a founder that
actually does have that mentality it's
probably a really good investment to
make for sure any words on a Bitcoin in
terms of like well I think everybody you
guys think about it I mean I think
anyone who having anyone can afford to
own some should should have should have
some bitcoins so I think that's pretty
pretty common pretty common wisdom I
mean we think of it as just an ultra
long term hold thing where you sort of
want to just have it and hold it and not
really not check the price for sort of
you know I haven't checked the price
years I haven't checked the price in a
long time and I don't want to check the
price for a number of years I really
preciate doing this my pleasure
yeah yeah where can people find you on
the internet you find me on Twitter
although I'm trying to use it less and
for all the especially now that that I
have all the controversial things I've
said on this podcast just g lu j ust G
le w and you can find us at a bedrock
capcom alright before I let you go I
always ask everybody about aliens are
you believer yes you know I definitely I
definitely think it's it's it's more
likely than not what is the logic as to
why you believe you know it's not it's
not an easy logical sort of train of
thought to deconstruct I'd say that um
it's actually pretty irrational on that
my face
book as a young person was contact and I
I want I want to believe that they're
these friendly aliens and it seems more
likely than not that given the vast is
that the universe there should be should
be intelligent life somewhere else out
there I've asked this question to over
220 people you're the first person to
basically say regardless of the logic or
not I want it to be true which I
actually think is a very honest view and
many other people probably that's why
they believe overwhelmingly people say
yes that it's likely but you're the
first person to say it that way we
always try and be always trying to be
honest the the yes always we got to try
and be honest him hypocrisy is a
hypocrisy is is is not a good not a good
luck I love it man alright well listen
thanks so much for coming to do this and
we'll definitely do it again my pleasure
thank you